Scofield and Alexander on the floor
familiar starting five for Tennessee are
the best defenders in the big ten what
it Williams to shoot that shot as
opposed to get there Poston dominate
where he can
with the reverse just two and a half
hours from West Lafayette the home of
the boiler Bank
he's been packed in heels wound up he is
fearless that happens
greatest distance race is to come
rejection
Tennessee coming in for the dunk nope
Eastern gives it to stefana Mitch he's
another good three-point shooter for
Purdue is Ansari and Edwards working on
Turner Classic Movies talked about this
his team but Tennessee averages 36
points in the paint
mad horns an outstanding defender and
he's already had a couple of steals in
this game has two assists as well his
client again the quick release backs at
three line fishing all day long
into the basket you can call it a hitch
you could call evictions Clyde against
cats inside harms takes a contact
for men horns
and here's time the three is up and
implied it's
that's what he did that time he comes
back rewarded with the stupid / dude low
turnovers but they forced turnover
Schofield 5 to 3
[Applause]
from the great white north second on the
shot clock
that's what team defense is all about
trust your teammates be vulnerable to
come from the back you who had a
12-point lead it to have extended it to
18 here is buries another triple Turner
behind the back Edwards checks it gives
out now let's go look at this and know
this is not the perfect situation for
Tennessee go with the pick and roll with
he and Edwards or at least the triple
handle is flying again folks you got
[Applause]
24 points shot clock down to nine Klein
can't dribble himself free he's gonna
have to take a long one five step back
three four the time
[Applause]
this dude 22 second half points 27 for
the game for Ryan Klein the finches
react
7
big
free-throw clutch by Carson Edwards
Tennessee has a timeout a valiant
comeback to force overtime
sapphire the beautiful slip everyone
thinks he's going to scream down is
actually a back screen by efforts on
that play beautiful sweet talker sit and
he draws the foul that he scores a cult
[Applause]
well this one coming to the finish line
Schofield against the last bucket in his
illustrious Tennessee career and the
Purdue Boilermakers out of the bed ten
headed to the Elite Eight